une eau turquoise un paysage
paradisiaque mais certains marins garde
un très mauvais souvenir de ses côtes
c'est le cas des six membres d'équipage
de ce remorqueur
pendant plus d'un mois et demi ils sont
restés otages à bord avec pour seul
horizon l'océan et ses falaises blanches
à 7000 kilomètres de là apple d'or dans
le sud de l'angleterre un homme a
toujours en mémoire ces cinquante jours
de captivité
le capitaine colline darche a bourlingué
sur toutes les mers du monde en 40 ans
de carrière il n'avait jamais connu une
attaque de pirates jusqu'au 1er février
dernier
c'était en train de me reposer
le chef mécanicien russe lui était sur
le pont tout à coup j'ai entendu des
cris j'ai grimper les escaliers
et j'ai vu un bateau qui arrivait très
vite
il ne tirait pas vraiment sur nous il
tirait juste pour nous effrayer
je n'ai pas vu d'impact de balles sur la
coque
mais quand même vous vous protégez donc
vous perdez le contrôle mais on a réussi
à maintenir ce bateau à distance
seulement un deuxième bateau est apparu
et quand il y en a deux c'est un peu
comme quand il ya de lyon sur la même
proie ça devenait impossible
[Musique]
l'abordage a eu lieu dans le golfe
d'aden
entre le yémen et la somalie une des
routes maritimes les plus fréquentées du
monde
remorqueur cargo mêmes yachts de luxe
comme le voilier français le ponant la
semaine dernière en 2007 plus de 150
attaques ont eu lieu au large de la
somalie
ce pays d'afrique de l'est ravagé par
des années de guerre civile détient le
record mondial des actes de piraterie
qui sont donc ces flibustiers des temps
modernes comment au père thil
cap sur le puntland
une région semi autonome de la somalie
un pays qui n'en est plus vraiment un le
puntland entre 2 et 3 millions
d'habitants le repaire des pirates
arrivé à bosasso capitale de la région
bienvenue à bossasso
un aéroport du bout du monde
pour seul trafic ici deux liaisons par
semaine avec djibouti
allait passer par ici
voilà le chef de l'immigration
des formalités vite expédiées
contre 20 dollars un visa fait au stylo
bille
les d'où il vient de cela
la présence d'étrangers étonne plus
personne ne vient à bossasso pas même
les ong après plusieurs kidnappings
les humanitaires ont tous plier bagage
la somalie est l'un des cinq pays les
plus pauvres du monde on vit ici avec
moins de 5 euros par mois
les principales ressources diane de la
mer
les habitants de bossasso vivent du
commerce avec le yémen voisin où les
pays du golfe en mer ils ont souvent à
faire aux pirates
les pêcheurs sont aussi leurs victimes
et en plus comme les bandits des mers
opère à partir des mêmes bateaux on les
confond souvent avec eux
bien sûr qu'on a peur des pirates et en
plus quand on est perdu en mer personne
ne vient à notre secours on nous confond
avec des pirates
nous on est victime des pirates nous
volent tout le poisson notre diesel
la piraterie le fléau de la région
ahmed said nur ministre de la pêche du
puntland et quand on occupe ce poste ici
les pirates c'est le dossier prioritaire
il tient à nous accompagner tout au long
de notre voyage
c'est paraît-il nécessaire sa présence
c'est notre assurance vie
parce que
vous avez c'est le raisons de sécurité
qui a été commencé après
alternat les street et relevé hier soir
ses relevés l'épaule on
est comme ça vous allez gagner de
l'argent
nous à l'import et vous aurez
c'est pour garder votre sécurité
pour espérer approcher les pirates qui
écument la région il faut se rendre à l
au bord de l'océan indien
bossasso elle 600 km de routes dont 202
mauvaise piste
un voyage sous escorte pour éviter les
enlèvements deux jours de 4 4 pour
atteindre les bords de l'océan indien
la cote des pirates après chaque attaque
ils mettent leurs prises à l'abri ici
sur des centaines de kilomètres des
criques des plages
ahmed n'a pas choisi cet endroit au
hasard
les pirates qui ont capturé le bateau du
capitaine anglais sont tout près
se calme oui
donc voilà ça c'est ça c'est le bateau
de rousseau si vous voulez les matchs
là-bas
au moment où nous tournons le capitaine
caudines darche n'est pas encore rentré
en angleterre il est toujours à bord
retenu en otage par une dizaine d'hommes
armés
les pirates somaliens peuvent garder les
équipages plusieurs mois le temps de
négocier avec l'armateur le montant de
la rançon
pour le capitaine darche et son équipage
il aura fallu débourser 500 mille euros
l'argent est la seule motivation des
pirates pendant la détention pas de
mauvais traitements et même de petites
attentions
on avait envie de boire un coup et on
n'avait plus de bière depuis plusieurs
semaines
alors un jour le chef des pirates nous a
dit je vais voir ce que je peux faire
pour vous
et trois fois ils nous apportaient du
jeans éthiopien regardez j'ai gardé les
étiquettes d'ailleurs
en quelque sorte c'est un cadeau du chef
des pirates
parfois ils venaient à bord et se
promener avec sa bouteille
je voyais le niveau de la bouteille qui
baissé à la fin il me l'a donnée mais
elle était à moitié vide
ce ne sont pas des tueurs fanatiques
comme ceux du hezbollah il vous met un
couteau sous la gorge et qui vous unit
peu tout ce qui les intéresse c'est
l'argent
je leur ai demandé ce qu'ils allaient
faire avec la rançon certains m'ont dit
qu'ils allaient s'acheter une nouvelle
femme ils ont droit à quatre femmes et
certainement avec deux ou trois
de mémoire le capitaine a dessiné le
seul horizon qu'il avait pendant sa
détention les falaises et les plages sur
lesquelles ses ravisseurs avaient
installé leurs bases arrières
tous les jours des bateaux faisait la
navette avec le rivage il apportait des
cigarettes du lait de chamelle et de
l'herbe enfin du cat
parfois deux ou trois de nos gardes
partez à terre plusieurs jours
il revenait avec les cheveux coupés et
assez en forme il y avait aussi des
femmes qui vivaient dans les tentes elle
faisait partie de leur famille
les villageois complice des pirates
c'est aussi la question que nous nous
étions posé lorsque nous étions sur les
traces des ravisseurs du capitaine
anglais à première vue rien ne distingue
leur bateau de ceux des pêcheurs
seulement les imposent leurs filets les
autres passent à l'abordage
les villageois se défendent de tout lien
avec les bandits des mers mais ils
profitent de leur présence pour
améliorer leur quotidien
ahmed le ministre de la pêche on est
convaincus
ou altérer
les pirates mais est-ce qu'on veut dire
comment allez vous frotter
les alésiens qui espère que les pirates
quand ils recevoir de l'argent et leur
donnerons quelque chose est tout
autrement c'est les berat
edel louis innocente et après la chaîne
nourriture et tout ça
comme par hasard quelques minutes après
notre arrivée des hommes se regrouper
nous barre la route certains sont armés
ce sont les complices des ravisseurs du
capitaine anglais ils ont sans doute été
prévenus par des villageois
alors on fait des misères
entre les scores du ministre et les
pirates les esprits s'échauffent
toi tu te calmes ce matin ce soir là bas
nous souhaitons nous rendre dans leurs
repaires et rencontré leur chef
le ministre va négocier pour nous c'est
pas gagné
moi je ne suis pas d'accord vous ne
viendrez pas dans mon village
et je ne veux pas leur parler
nous ne cherche pas la guerre
mais si vous voulez le créer des
problèmes
ou nous faire peur ça ne va pas marcher
allez-y et vous verrez bien ce qui va
vous arriver
vous êtes peut-être armée mais nous
aussi
c'est pas la peine de nous menacer
c'est pas vous qui allez nous faire peur
le ministre décide de passer en force
tout va bien tout va bien
tout ne va pas si bien la preuve ahmed
renforce la sécurité
là vous avez mis deux hommes armés à
l'arrière pourquoi en peine dans des
mesures sécurité oui parce que la même
portée par l'amour que
peut-être la guerre c'est la guerre bien
qui va commencer
oui vous allez on est vraiment en jeu
mais vous êtes très relax en même temps
non pas très relax et bosco la borne
effectif
mais ça 55 cartes
ahmed en fait une question d'honneur le
ministre ne veut pas se laisser
impressionner par des bandits
mais quelques kilomètres plus loin les
pirates nous bloquent à nouveau la route
cette fois les menaces se font plus
précises
toi et tes zone
vous pouvez rester chez nous autant que
vous voulez un jour où des mois
mais pas les étrangers nous ne sommes
pas des ennemis on n'a rien contre toi
il y à là bas 200 sommes bien armés qui
se prépare pour vous attaquer
ils savent que tu veux venir avec des
journalistes étrangers
je te le répète pour toi il n'ya aucun
problème puis ici chez toi
les attentions si les étrangers viennent
chez nous et film ce qui se passe je te
préviens il risque d'avoir de sérieux
problèmes
les pirates ont gagné personne ne
viendra déranger leur business
nouvelle qu'on les oublie il faut qu'on
les oublie voilà c'est ça
ils veulent qu'on les oublie
le ministre doit rebrousser chemin dans
sept régions de somalie ce sont les
pirates qui dicte la loi et face aux
bandes armées les autorités ne font pas
le poids
le puntland comme le reste de la somalie
fait tout pour sauver les apparences
mais cela n'amuse personne pas même au
palais présidentiel à bossasso devant la
caméra le président de la région le
général adé n'a aucune gêne à
reconnaître son impuissance
[Musique]
maintenant nous avons la marine
française les britanniques
les allemands les américains ils ne
peuvent pas les arrêter comment voulez
vous que nous on y arrive
vous savez le problème c'est que nous
nous ne payons jamais de rançon
les français payent des rançons les
britanniques payent les américains aussi
payer des rançons
c'est une grosse erreur
très grosse erreur pas une grosse erreur
une très grosse erreur
il encourage les pirates
ils achètent des armes maintenant les
combats s'intensifient parce qu'ils ont
des nouveaux armements
il s'équipe aussi en transport
communication et tout le reste
les pirates somaliens s'enrichissent et
se renforce le puntland lui ne dispose
que de deux bateaux pour surveiller 1300
km de côtes les équipements rouillé
dérisoire par rapport à la puissance de
feu des pirates sans aide internationale
les prises d'otages comme celle du
ponant risquent de se multiplier